yes slobs um today we're going to talk
about
our thought process yeah you too uh
behind uh
uh behind our uh our video for us we're
gonna watch some deleted scenes we're
gonna respond to some viewer comments
and questions uh from the video itself
and in the live chat over there if
you're here right now
and we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer sounds like a good time
right boys
let's let's do it uh lon joe
how are us doing today what'd you think
of us
there was a time oh no no no no
not for 45 minutes i can't stop for 45
minutes even even lupita was like
pushing it
a little um i really
like this movie uh right up until the
point where it start tries to explain
what it is
and um when it tries to fill out its
wikipedia entry
uh and stops being a pure allegory
uh and then it starts to get rough um
my first note i wrote down on upon my us
rewatch
was that to me it's the shining if the
shining
actually had all of the stuff that the
conspiracy theories
insist that's in it like if the shining
was actually about all of those things
uh that's us jordan peele just had a lot
of ideas and i guess was worried he
wasn't gonna get a third crack at it
i don't know yeah i i think i put this
in my in my notes as well when i first
watched it like
i feel like there's a better version of
this movie that just
doesn't explain it it's just like you
could sort of wrap it up in the same
kind of way but just leave it more
ambiguous as to
where did these doubles come from and
like what do they
really want like what's their nature
because yeah he does
manage to explain it but it feels like
it's it's so complicated
and it kind of doesn't work out when you
start thinking about it later
like it sort of works when you're
watching the movie and then later you're
like
and if we deal with this in the trailer
like there's just a lot of dangling
threads where it's like i don't know if
i really buy this tethered situation
yeah i agree um i think that there is
something like
genuinely haunting about you know uh
some repressed part of you or
the dark side of you the part you keep
underground coming up to the surface to
kill you
that's all you need to know um you don't
need to know that the government was
started the super secret research lab my
question is why why does he keep doing
this i mean he didn't get out
he did it in this movie like i guess
hitchcock does it
as we pointed out in the trailer like
why is he afraid that we're gonna
dismiss this if we're we're gonna be
asking too many questions afterwards
because this only generated more
questions for us
i mean he the dude loves twilight zone
obviously
so i i i think there's a you know
something to be said for a style he's
maybe going for uh where you know you
have the third act
guy come in and just be like well you
see here's what's happening in psycho
um whereas i
i like the move like it's beautifully
shot like it's
incredibly creepy um
and i i just don't need answers yeah i'm
not sure i totally agree
get out definitely has this beat where
it's like the brain surgery and like
let's really dig into the explanation
but i almost feel like that's more what
i wanted from us like you get like it's
a ginger
sort of sprinkling of an explanation but
you don't really need to spend that much
time in that world exploring
how exactly they're being john malkovich
into new bodies
like it like the being john malkovich
version is like perfect like that's
show me a graphic where it's like no
it's like everybody's got a portal and
then you enter their brain you're like
great i get it okay done
and like i feel like get out it's it's
it's still that beat but it is more
gracefully sort of managed
and it keeps more about the character
and the scenario then
and now here's an explanation for this
whereas us it's really like
wait how where who built this facility
and
what's going on with these rabbits like
it's just it's there's so much that it's
like
too much too quickly and it kind of
falls apart right now
where are we single i would say i i
agree with joe that up until then it's
super effective like it's a really
good clever take on the you know home
invasion
sort of horror movie uh yeah i just
don't like the last sort of seven
minutes
yeah and i would just say it seems at
odds with the rest of
his filmmaking style which is to kind of
layer on symbolism and illusions
and like kind of hints and nods to what
he's really talking about that to just
state it like to to like you said like
do a print out of a wiki at the end
it it seemed like it went against
everything else you've been trying to
build towards which is
vibes and mood and uh and metaphor
so there you go uh it's a really good
film um
i would recommend everybody watch it and
then come up with your own explanation
don't listen to uh
to what they have to say uh donnie darko
your own
your own fan theory into it um yeah just
that's another great example actually
because the theatrical cut leaves it
very sort of
vague like is this all in his head or
whatever and then the director's cut is
like here's exactly what's happening
they put in a literal excerpt from the
book explaining it yeah like oh the
theatrical is way better
and look when i was a young man i very
much appreciated here's everything
that's in the history of time travel but
i'm not of course not that young boy
anymore just play the gary jewell song
and send me on my way i'm good
all right let's let's watch the odds
trailer for us
[Music]
from scare jordan comes his follow-up to
the creepiest body swap movie since nine
lives
oh madison i've been a bad kitty
in a smash hit packed with enough social
commentary
to trick snobs into watching more
b-movie sci-fi horror flicks
i only watch for the complex racial
allegories
that's uh the dred scott decision
uh um
i saw one person in the comments who who
thinks that saying b movies
stands for black movies it does not
stand for black movies
it is although i don't know what it does
stand for i thought it was just like a
b c like like grades like movies would
have been like the big like romances and
musicals that played on like huge
theaters and then
b movies would have been genre stuff
that was more niche that would play in
smaller what do they think a c movie
is don't ask joe keep going
enter the twisted nightmare of having to
spend time in the woods with your lame
ass parents
you don't need the internet you got the
outer net plus your dad's crappy work
friends
what do we say i hate you and some
ashley
i was just so delighted to see
uh tim hydeker and elizabeth moss in
these roles
i do think that he has a great way of
casting america's favorite white people
as as these side [ __ ] characters in
his boobies with uh bradley whitford in
the last one
and now high decker is like oh good oh
good
uh he got one of the tim and eric's uh
yeah i think it was great casting yeah
no undefeated there
yeah it's a i mean it's good too because
it's it's a little bit of shorthand like
you kind of get who this character is
right away just based on the casting
before
like he doesn't have to do that much
work before you're like i understand who
this guy is
uh all right keep going i hate you and
some ashy relatives your mom never told
you about
in a film that black people can finally
point to and say
hanging out with family sucks for us too
you know we made it
experience powerhouse duel performances
by great actors
unleashing their full range of crazy
faces
that's got to be fun right yeah
[Music]
yeah you know elizabeth moss enjoyed
shooting that uh like can we all do our
best us
crazy face yeah
i ate rabbit
[Applause]
i'm drinking an orange mango split
how did she do that like extensively
like that if
you could i feel like you could hear her
throat being scratched
i think it was like the tenacious d like
because i'm always [ __ ]
rocking and i never stop singing in him
[Laughter]
keep going anchored by lupita nyong'o
making a futile attempt to not look like
a goddess
who puts other actors to shame with her
left tear duct alone
[Music]
and winston duke a man with truly
frightening levels of bde
hey big dad energy
i'm just gonna watch the giants
highlights okay
uh apparently that shot of winston duke
spread eagled on the bed was like it
gave rise to a lot of
some feelings in some women and like i
guess that's just the difference between
the male and female gays because i saw
that
that shot and i was like he looks like
uh like that
what a slob like but but i guess that's
a that's a big turn on
i think it's the thighs it's the time
yeah we're in the
the era of like zaddy daddy
energy and like suddenly this is
apparently more appealing
than you would have thought yeah yeah
it's the the
the thighs and shorts uh i just felt
like it was an unflattering angle but
yeah i guess my eyes weren't on the
thighs but like if you shoot
someone from below keep your eyes on the
thighs baby also yeah i mean just like
black panther sort of cemented winston
duke as like a sex symbol so now
he's just got fans who are gonna be into
it whatever yeah put him in the short
shorts
yeah exactly who wears dad shorts
all right keep going you know in any
other horror movie he'd be the dumb jock
who dies first
got a cassette player at everything
leather seats
[Music]
see what a real messed up family looks
like with the arrival
of the tethered doppelgangers with
matching gold scissors
special op hand gestures
and adventure brothers speed suits i
look like santa's magic janitor
they're part of a subterranean club who
walk like sims
talk like they spent the night doing
when the slayer
was hungry she had to eat rabbit
raw and bloody and go down like a bunch
of pongs
what's so scary about yourself trying to
kill you no one sucks more than me
i do think that the the tethered look a
metaphor it's an allegory it's movie
logic but like
i don't know this is america everyone's
got guns
they all they have is really the element
of surprise and they don't even use that
like they just kind of
show up on your doorstep and wave like
yeah i mean i think
like in one version of this like i feel
like the thing that would be scary about
the tethered is like
they're they're animalistic like they're
not
civilized or whatever like human so they
would just come at you and it's
unpredictable and
chaotic and that's why they would be a
threat but they're not they're like
methodical like
a person like here we have a plan let me
tell you what we're coming up with
so in that context there's not really
anything super dangerous about them
they're just like
malnourished and all they have are
scissors and
like they kind of don't really have an
elaborate scheme
to they just show up at your door and
hope to scare you and it's like
that's why i i like yeah they're
allegories you know so much more than
an explained lab experiment because
there's something interesting to me
about like
you know we're taking the rage infection
idea from 28 days later
and we're putting it in um uh instead of
zombies
uh people like the tethered who can
still like
focus it and think and process and
they're still you know very like
sentient with it like that idea of just
like
hey there's generations of repressed
anger and undealt with
like just [ __ ] and that's what they
represent and it's scary
like i like that a lot more than
that a man made them in a lab yeah and
if you didn't have that explanation you
could
have them do things like like zombies
where you can hit them and they keep
coming at you like in this
if you whack it with a golf club like
that's it it's like a person you just
like knock them out and then they're
done
but like right like zombies that's what
makes zombies a threat like they're slow
and they're kind of slumping and they
can't think
good but like you know you can hit them
a bunch of times and they'll keep coming
you have to like cut off their head or
you know whatever
um yeah i just i think that some of the
some of the horror action could probably
work a little better just because the
theta
aren't that much of a threat but it's
also just a funny bit to string together
though
give them like mech suits you know and
then like they have bees in their mouth
and when they yell they shoot bees
we're already going to the point of some
how they got
driving gloves and scissors so like they
couldn't have just gotten like
glocks instead like just why stop it
just give them swords at least or
something it's symbolic lon
keep going follow jordan peel on his
evolution into the modern day hitchcock
who crafts deeply unsettling mysteries
then dumps exposition on you in the
final act like the last scene of psycho
he was simply doing everything possible
to keep alive the illusion of his mother
being alive
because while the tether sadly the the
motivation i read about the
screenwriter's motivation for putting
that in there was
they were afraid that people would watch
the end of psycho and think he was a
homosexual
so they had to put that scene in there
explaining that no it's not very
uh uh guys no it's deeply freudian and
complex
that makes it even funnier in a in a way
because like
originally in the trailer we had his
whole explanation
uh lengthy yeah the idea and it's
already sort of infuriating to be like
what they just pump the brakes right at
the end of psycho so this guy can talk
for 20 minutes okay
but like the idea that they were so
worried about that that they pump the
brakes is
hilarious yeah there's so many layers
wrong with like
they're worried that the audience will
see him dressed in women's clothing and
think
oh uh he's killed because he's a
homosexual
like yeah then that they needed to sort
that out with them
no you guys because he's obsessed with
his mother and has a split personality
yeah come on get your head out of the
gutter yeah
i mean cast the first stone am i
uh right fun fact uh all right keep
going
as while the tethered were scarily
effective as an allegory
the explanation that they're actually an
underground experiment raises a few
questions
like is there a tethered for everyone in
america
how is there enough space underground
for them people on the channel
about these experiments how did no one
find out in the last 30 years surely
they were using enough electricity water
and raw materials to raise some red
flags can the tether control their
actions independently or not if not how
are they executing this complicated plan
if so why do they bother staying
underground do the people who made the
tether forget to lock the door in their
way out how do they have the same body
type as their dog their diet is one
hundred percent rabbit meat they tend to
take the rabbits
rabbits eat where they get thousands if
not millions of red juices and scissors
however we create everything in the
smaller
silly just like classrooms and hallways
what about people living part of the
buildings how they make vertical
differences are there just piles of poop
in the tunnels to your tether when you
travel to the country they just wait
so grab your buddies to take the
ultimate horror rorschach test
where you'll see a bunny and think ah
clever nod to the black folktale
tradition of bray rabbit
or huh jordan beal must have really
hated his toy story 4 character
to infinity and your mom
or you know what sometimes a rabbit is
just a rabbit now get your head out of
your ass and go back to the stabby
stabby
you understand
say uh pause um in an interview with
jordan peeler that i read
he's just scared of rabbits he just
thinks they're creepy
i like that unless that's a misdirect
for the interview where he's like yeah i
just think they're scary like
he's really like oh messing with you and
telling you to figure it out
i assumed it was because rabbits
breed a lot and you would need so much
food to feed
everybody down there that that's why
they went with rabbits yeah but like it
goes beyond that like there's
like the the daughters wearing like
rabbits on her shirt and like
there's like a lot of rabbit symbolism
throughout there more so than just like
it's a food source
definitely i was just saying to me that
seemed like the lodge like if you wanted
to offer a
explanation in addition to the motif of
rabbits
there's it seems like that would be that
was what i assumed the explanation would
be
but yeah of course with rabbit what
other animal is just going to repopulate
although they the
we brought it up in there what are the
rabbits eating like how are you going to
raise generation after jail i don't see
any carrots
or were they growing lettuce somewhere
underground
oh yeah yeah it's it's it's no way to
eat a bracer or cornies you know
you need potatoes you need some mashed
potatoes
in the big waiting room that's around
the entire u.s border where your
tethered sits when you go to canada
uh yeah i guess that's where there's
hobbits cooking up all of these
delicious ponies you know there's only
one way to eat a brace a coney's lung
yeah you too joe
that's what i that's something i kind of
do love about the movie is because uh
you know i was looking
i was like okay what's everyone think
everything and us means
and um like with the scissors they were
like what's up with the scissors and he
was like well no one's really there's
that hasn't really been a slasher with
scissors so i wanted to use an
unassuming object that no one's really
used and so scissors
and then like what i love about it is
then
the next like four paragraphs of the
article where the writer being like but
here's what it could also be
and that's why i kind of love about this
movie yes
i i think that clearly that was
intentional like even if he's not
letting on
in interviews and even if not it's like
oh you know death of death of the author
we can we can say what it means because
it's clearly like
you know sethered sever the tether you
know you you snip the tether with the
scissors and it like it looks like
like a dual thing like scissors it
visually works as a metaphor
it's also it's an everyday thing that we
all use in our lives and don't think of
as being dangerous
but then if you flip it in this
different way and see it in this new
light they're very dangerous
because they can kill you and so it's
like in that us way if it's like it's a
the dual nature like
there's the thing we use it for which is
to cut things and be helpful around the
house
but then there's this other thing where
it could kill you yeah
uh yeah and also i would add that
there's a 90s kenneth branagh movie
called dead again with emma thompson
it's terrific
and it is also about a killer who uses
scissors so
come on red jumpsuit no no
no other elements of this movie i don't
think
although no that's not true uh it
flashes between two timelines and so
both kenneth branagh
and emma thompson play dual roles so
there is
there is another us connection maybe a
favorite movie of jordan
same movie we'd be original jordan
all right let's keep going watch that
again
underrated a very good 90s film
starring mom skanata
zora neal hurton thigh master
[Music]
article spaghett l'oreal
because you're worth it and twins
uh pause there were a lot of other uh
tim neric ideas for for that um
i think my favorite was was uh aside
from spaghett was
giving the movie five bags of popcorn
but since it's a dual roll ten bags of
popcorn
but i i was going to insist if we had
included that one that that
we needed the voice to do it in an on
center like uh i'm i'm gonna give it uh
five five bags of popcorn but since
there are two of them uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna go ten
ten bags you know like you got if it's
not that halting delivery it doesn't
feel offense
so yes everyone if you didn't get those
references please watch the timing eric
sketch spaghett
and the on cinema verse watch please
watch all 12 seasons of
on cinema at the cinema and mr america
the spin-off documentary
all right anyways uh keep going we're
almost done
attack of the clones
based on how frequently they appear in
movies you think people are walking
through halls of mirrors like every day
yeah right it's a it's another one of
those things like a kissing booth
they show up much more often in film
than they do in real life well i was
thinking when i was watching the scene
in the movie i was like have i
have i ever once in my life been in a
hall of mirrors like i'm not
actually sure that i have i think i've
done it like
once as like a section of a fun house in
a carnival like
it's right but it's it's basically one
of those experiences that we
only think of in cinematic terms like
it's a thing that's in movies that's not
really in life yeah i've been in like a
room that had
different trick mirrors in it in a fun
house for sure but that's like the ones
that make you look like super tall
yeah i've never been in a hall of
mirrors no not not like a john wick
us like full-on like you can't tell
it doesn't seem like it would even be
safe or fun
it's not no i would panic right like
what why would this exist other than it
looks cool in a move
well field trip idea after uh this is
all over
meet you there um guys if you've been
watching this uh
long and far you might as well sign up
for our next phantom 5 trivia show
which is um october 30th a week from
friday
it's about star wars and if you sign up
now and click the link in the
description
you can win some real money no imperial
credits no portions real cold hard
american cash
um and uh i'm not sure what aspects of
star wars it'll be about
china it's gonna it's it's the films so
all nine movies plus the spin-off
theatrical film so don't worry about
ewok adventure caravan of courage stuff
i mean worry about it but not for this
worry about the holiday special but not
for this so
so the theatrically released films
including you know solo rogue one
and then mandalorian season one
that's it all right so now we're not
doing clone wars none of the animated
shows either mandala live action tv
and films great core star wars if you
will
uh and then uh speaking real star wars
that counts yeah the real st
cannon uh speaking of easy uh click
like and subscribe to this channel if
you haven't already i mean come on
you've watched this much
uh why not watch more uh click the bell
hit that like
and uh that should take us into our
outtakes uh what did we cut from this
one with our
scissors probably at least eight
terminals
yes i only watch for the complex racial
allegories
that's uh the dred scott decision
that's the raid on harper's ferry
voting rights in a film that black
people can finally point to and say
hanging out with family sucks for us too
you know is that why the kids are always
wandering off to get snatched
say son jason
jason jason jason
i mean if these were my parents i'd take
my chances with a bloody hobo
we made it
i'm sorry but one racist cop with a gun
could handle this in an afternoon and he
wouldn't even have to plant a bloody
leather glove
oh my god it's oj starring
two peters
i gave it five bags of popcorn but it
actually has double so it's actually ten
bags of popcorn
tim's awesome movie great job under
their eye
and this is us oh run
sister sister the paired red trap
and that's all all right um cool
well uh them's the outtakes how about
these comments um
adam holbert writes do you think jordan
peele is really putting himself
into the winston duke character uh
you think he sees himself as like a
cornball
uh uh oh fish dad who
doesn't acknowledge the the uh
rumbling stuff just beneath the surface
i feel like get out you could probably
read is more
sort of like informed by personal
experience or semi-autobiographical this
one feels very explicitly like taking
some ideas from
horror movies and kind of
recontextualizing them like i don't i
don't know if i would read
any one person in this movie being the
jordan eel
character yeah i mean i think it's a
personal film in the sense that like
he is scared of or wanted to make a
movie about like the fear of the things
just below the surface of like the
things we've ignored and
especially historically that we've uh
like the the
underclass of america that's uh that we
try to
not pay attention to you know bursting
under the surface but i don't think that
it's like a
beyond his own i don't think there was
one character that stood in for jordan
peele yeah yeah and i mean i think like
working like it's it it does
represent jordan people in terms of like
things that he likes and that interests
him and like movies genres and ideas
that he wanted to explore
in a way that was personally meaningful
to him i think there's a lot of that
like there's so many like family
vacation kind of stories and tropes that
he's like
working through in this and i mean
that's personal in a way but uh yeah i
don't think i read it as like oh yeah
this is totally like
he's jason was him as a kid or anything
yeah uh daryl george writes does it
bother anybody that the hall of mirrors
attraction is facing the beach where
there's basically no foot traffic
really bad peer layout design um yeah i
mean i also read that
as like it's um again it's sort of in
this hazy
is it metaphorical is it real like it's
almost like
when he sees the zoltar machine and big
where it's like almost
supernaturally there just for her to
find it
oh yeah that would that that whole
attraction was like a
was the hall of metaphors it wasn't the
hall of mirrors like it had a big thing
outside that said find yourself
um and then like it started out with
native american imagery and then years
later they like paved it over and turned
it into like
wizard imagery like it was the whole
it's it's metaphors people all the way
down it's very disney
like uh pay no attention to the racist
animals outside this log ride
because uh knott's berry farm used to
have an attraction it's exactly like the
original holo mirrors that she goes to
where it was like
an old native american like telling you
stories about like the raven
and whatever and like every time i see
this uh movie it reminds me of that
weird old
it wasn't a ride it was like a show um
sir friend rights i want to see winston
duke and the tsa guy forgot his name
uh from that would be little rel howery
from get out do some kind of road movie
yes i would like that too sure that
sounds delightful
yeah put them put them together let's do
it
uh lavetto writes uh in honor of drunk
sju chat oh
congratulations what movie would improve
if the main characters were all drunk
the whole time
wow sorry to spring that one on you i
mean would us
better if everyone was bombed like the
kids
if like the children were just drunk i
mean i guess the tethered are already
sort of like what would change and and
heidecker and elizabeth moss are drunk
yeah they are
yeah a heist movie right like ocean's
eleven but they're drunk and they get
caught and it doesn't work or something
like that
we're gonna do this guys it's only gonna
work that's just the original
like they legit were drunk the entire
time
yeah all right well that's one of the
things i almost feel like it would be
something like apollo 13.
like you want it to be like people who
are already in an incredibly intense
situation
then it's just heightened like imagine
if they're like they're in helms deep
waiting for saruman's army to arrive
but they're just bombed like that
apologies
i like the idea of like apollo 13 doing
a disaster movie because i think that
they would just like really take it in
stride like cusack in 2012 was just like
all right
let's just just get the limo we're just
gonna go we're just kind of
i guess poseidon adventure it like does
open during a new year's eve party so
they're at least
buzzed when the the accident first
begins but yeah i'd love to see like
dante's peak but brosnan is just like
he's already had eight martinis there's
love over here
there's a lot of movies that i think
would be improved if the actors had been
bombed like while filming
and a lot of your favorite movies were
the actors
um all right final final question you
guys uh
um from charles clark very important did
the tethered also go through a papa
roach phase
i think they did they would have had to
have if you did
you're tethered did this yeah those and
these papa roach existed there was a
tethered popper wrote there was a tether
he roach down there doing that papa
roach like awesome because they're the
opposite of our like
like are there is their version of creed
like the best band
wow interesting but they were the
tethers weren't the opposite they were
just like
you know like they just made too many
photocopies of your face like
their nickelback is just like wow don't
even go there
well i i think i think their their their
version of pop roach is scarier
because the tether is supposed to be all
of the like unsurfaced anger and
aggression that like you haven't
expressed
and like papa roach pretty much came out
swinging with
cutting their lives into pieces oh with
the scissors
it's already their last resort on this
side so imagine what their
underground yeah i think honestly
chances are
papa roach was like a very sunny pop
punk band that went into that hall of
mirrors and just got switched out
so they are oh right they they switched
like yes just like in the movie
papa roach are tethered you heard it
here first people all right well that
was fun
um uh please continue this discussion in
the comments below because i know
we got a lot of prompts for you what
movie would be better if everyone was
drunk and what would paparoach sound
like
uh uh if they were tethered yeah what
but imagine forest theaters
please join us again next week for more
hijinks uh where we will be talking
about
something um
uh something it's hard to get a read
on it at least on the face of it it's
hard
it's tough to get a read um so you will
find out exactly what we're talking
about when you come back next week
right here different time same day for
honest trailer commentaries
thanks again for watching see you later
[Music]
you